about a week ago the BBC published this
article which was detailing results from
National Teachers Convention on poverty
in schools and how poverty it was one of
the largest obstacles to student
achievement in schools in the UK and
this got me thinking especially with a
general election coming up education
issues in this country are described
very much from the top down where the
teachers was betting on things and this
is understandable but the students
perspective is completely ignored and
you never really see it reported in the
media so I wanted to ask you guys not
just about this poverty issue in schools
the question I'll ask you guys is what
do you think is the single biggest issue
in education in the UK right now now
your answer could be a small-scale issue
like what goes on syllabuses class sizes
the way in which you're tall or it could
be a big issue like the nature of the
exam session on how we're assessed when
we take exams the general progression
from school to university it can be
whatever you think is the single biggest
thing you'd like to change and if you
can think of something how would you
like to change that issue how would you
improve it I've been very lucky to have
some fantastic two-way conversations
with people on this channel before and
I'm really really interested to see what
those come up with so please comment
down below with your answers or if you'd
like you can do a video response and tag
me in it and let's get a conversation
going and more than just you guys
because chances are if you watch this
video you're very motivated you're
probably thinking about going to
Oxbridge and you're a high achiever in
your school that might not be the case
but more likely than not it probably is
but I want the general student
perspective I don't just want a skews
sample of the student population so put
this on your Facebook on your Twitter um
I want to hear from everybody on here
from everybody in your school about what
you guys think is the single biggest
issue not just from your school but
across education as a whole as a concept
in this country so please get commenting
get video-making get messaging whatever
and I'm really interested to hear what
you guys have to say also as a quick
update in about weeks time I'm going to
be starting a short series on exam
preparation and exam technique I realize
that we're going into the exam season at
the moment and hopefully a lot of you
are very deep into your revision
strategies already but this will be
hopefully a bit of motivation and it'll
be
to sharpen your skills and that's just
give me a few videos in that series
coming up on this channel slightly
starting from about next week and them
from there we'll see how quickly I can
do them if you'd like to stay updated
about that by the way you can follow me
at Simon Oxford's on Twitter and I now
have a Facebook page facebook.com
forward slash You Tube Simon because I'm
really imaginative and I'll be posting
updates about what's going on and also I
realized that YouTube subscription box
is kind of a little bit broken so I'll
be putting my videos on both of those
platforms as well right thanks for
watching and get commenting